so you took it over the next few months
you think you could have a vaccine
at the earliest a year to a year and a
half by september
ready for deployment we cannot put a
date on when we will get
a vaccine predictions about when a
vaccine for covert 19 may be ready
very wildly to say the least so what's
the truth
first the good news there's probably
never been a better time for mankind
to need a new vaccine exciting advances
in biotech and
outbreaks like sars and ebola have
galvanized huge progress just when we
need it most
at the australian centre for disease
preparedness animal trials are already
underway on two vaccines
one from the us and one from britain's
oxford university
that's only possible so soon because of
leaps in technology
these vaccines are very novel um and
there has never been a
one that's actually made it all the way
to licensing
but they certainly have been
demonstrated to
induce uh parts of the immune system uh
so the question is
um will they produce a sufficient level
of stimulation
and is it to the right arms of the
immune system in such a way that it can
prevent the development of disease
scientists learnt a lot from the sars
outbreak in china almost two decades ago
gave them insights into a similar kind
of virus to clovid 19
leading to big breakthroughs and giving
grounds for more optimism the sheer
number and variety of labs and companies
now pursuing a vaccine possibly as many
as a hundred
separate efforts are underway i'm
hopeful that
some of these endeavors come to fruition
and we will have a vaccine in the end
the methods are diverse in israel these
scientists believe research on
coronaviruses in chickens
will help them make an oral vaccine for
humans soon
but they like everyone else know that
even if they're successful
a new vaccine could be held up for
months if not years
by a lengthy approval process they want
that changed
i think that under these circumstances
we should consider again
what is bureaucracy and what is
essential
to bring a safe and effective vaccine to
the people
and we hope that everyone will be
reasonable and that will find their way
africa's ebola outbreak showed that with
an epidemic moving at
wildfire speed you can fast track
vaccine production and approval
the hope is the same can happen now
normally you test the new vaccine first
on animals which could take one or two
years
then start clinical tests on a group of
people first to see if it's safe then if
it does actually stop the virus
and that could take another two years
only then do you test it on much
larger groups that could potentially
take a lot more time taking it up to
eight years
or more with the first curve in 19
vaccines they're doing the first test at
the same time testing on animals
and on humans and gambling on starting
to manufacture it too
and authorities say they'll scrap any
unnecessary red tape to make this period
of time
even shorter but there are just too many
unknowns
to say how much shorter veterans of the
vaccine industry are working overtime
to manage our expectations i think
people are envisaging that would be
we would be out of lockdown in a few
weeks
whatever we do with vaccines they're not
going to be available
in a few weeks there may be some other
treatments that demons
are demonstrated to work reasonably well
and they may be available in a short
time but vaccines are not going to be
available in that
kind of time frame and the most sobering
fact of all we may never find a vaccine
there still isn't one for instance
against hiv or the common cold
the need has never been greater the
technology never more promising
and around the world scientists are
scrambling to become the ones that beat
this pandemic
but there is undoubtedly still a long
way to go
dominic waghorn sky news